This is irresponsible.
The public school teachers don't even want the Bill.
They're not even asking you for this.
We just passed legislation and have FROs in every school.
Can we see if that works yet?
I'm upset. Not out of because I don't like you all individually,
because I'm mad cause this Bill puts my child at risk.
And all the mothers out here that just got put out,
they're saying their children at risk.
Look at that gallery.
They're asking you not to do this.
Put partisan politics aside.
I ask you this all the time,
but this Bill is dangerous.
Don't do it. Teachers don't want it,
the school districts don't want it.
Nobody doesn't want it.
It's not gonna work.
It's going to cause more school shootings.
What happened today is a gallery full of mothers who are concerned
and we put them out because you trying to put guns in teachers hands.
We ought to be ashamed.
Mrs. Speaker.